et
[Musique]
avant de commencer notre feuilleton une
lise au point s'impose beaucoup de nos
téléspectateurs s'étaient plaints des
shadoks disait qu'il était complètement
idiot ça n'avait pas de sens et en
conséquence à ne présentait aucun
intérêt ou éducatif
sauf éventuellement pour les chats les
chiens et les demeurait moto at-on nous
de dire que c'était les spectateurs là
avait entièrement raison et ont fait
preuve d'une très grande perspicacité et
intelligence
un shadok plus de prêts en effet quelque
chose de complètement idiot voyez plutôt
[Musique]
c'est pas de chance non plus bien quand
ça en a un c'est jamais le bon quant au
point de vue culture éducation n'en
parlons pas il serait donc injuste
d'imposer à ses téléspectateurs le
scandaleux spectacles d'animaux ou
zurich
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi si nous avons cédé malgré
tout devant l'assistance des shadoks
pour apparaître à partir d'aujourd'hui
sur vos écrans
c'est à la condition formelle et express
qu'il ferait un effort réel et sincère
pour développer leur intelligence et
relever ainsi de le niveau éducatif et
culturel de leurs émissions les shadoks
l'ont promis dans la suite des émissions
nous pourrons donc assisté quand les
péripéties de l'histoire nous en
laissons le loisir à l'éducation des
châteaux de cours de culture générale et
de culture physique cours de
mathématiques de mécanique cours de
chant
de musique
en
[Musique]
de danse et quantité d'autres arts table
et que nos téléspectateurs sera sue dans
très peu de temps
les shadoks seront aussi intelligent
civilisé des cultivé que vous et moi ils
seront enfin composer un spectacle digne
de vous être présenté
enfin espérons
[Musique]